[Music]
these are the only survivors
of an air strike which killed most of
the majali family
the attack pretty much leveled their
home but the accounts of what happened
by the sole survivors
and the many witnesses we interviewed
have made the saudi coalition's position
unsustainable
after months of delay the coalition has
admitted they made a mistake
they bombed the wrong house
these inhospitable mountains were where
the majali family lived
now thrust into the front line of a
civil war that's tearing their country
apart
we've put together the most detailed
account yet about the massacre that
happened here
it's an attack which has now led to a
rare admission
by the saudi-led coalition that they
were responsible
for wrongly killing nine innocent
civilians
we found from the missile here's what
our investigation found out about that
airstrike
washer is close to the saudi border with
several air bases nearby
king khalid is closest making it the
most likely based the jet left from
it flew over the village for about an
hour starting around noon time on july
12
2020 12 members of the majali family
were in and around their single story
modern stone home
and it had six rooms mrs jumma majali
was making lunch with her two
daughters-in-law
nawal and noora about an hour later they
served the meal
and called the eight children together
to eat in the living room
her teenage daughter nasim left to the
bathroom and daughter-in-law nourah
went to a bedroom to breastfeed her baby
kanas mrs majali's teenage son ghazi was
watching tv next door
when the missile struck at ten past one
all those in the living room were killed
so was naseem in the bathroom
only teenage ghazi in one of the back
bedrooms
survived but was badly burned alongside
nora and her baby
who had minor wounds because they too
were at the rear of the house
in all nine of them died that day
we were the first journalists and the
only outsiders to reach the site of the
attack
several weeks after it happened
we gathered a pile of evidence and sent
our team
back to get more
the only survivors now live hundreds of
kilometers away but we tracked them down
i was screaming for help i was in shock
she says the house was destroyed i was
searching for my daughter but she was
dead
then i saw my sister-in-law and she was
dead too i just picked up my son
and screamed for help
mrs majali's teenage son ghazi is in a
separate home again far away
he can't remember much but his cousins
can
we only recognize his mother from her
torso
that was all that was left of his mother
he only managed to identify
one of the small children from his face
it was his brother's son his arms were
cut off
and his sister-in-law she had no leg and
no arm
and she was totally burned
it struck us then how remote the house
was despite claims from the coalition
about a possible military target there
everywhere you look around here there
are small farms there's little
residential clusters there's
homes and mountains it's very difficult
to see
what around here could be conceived of
as a legitimate
military target
yemen's been embroiled in a civil war
for the last five years
on one side as a coalition of nations
led by saudi arabia and backed by
britain
the u.s and the uae they're fighting
houthi rebels who control most of the
north with the support of iran
the conflicts created the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
we filmed some of the millions suffering
from malnutrition and disease
in yemen's most desperate areas when we
were last there
[Music]
since our reports the uns investigated
the bombing as a possible war crime
the coalition would have been aware of
this and ahead of us broadcasting these
fresh details
admitted they'd made a mistake
there was a military target they say but
it was nearly
800 meters away in the completely
separate area of bait al qasim
and they blamed poor weather in a
statement they said
the joint forces believed that the bomb
did not hit the target due to
intermittent clouds over the target area
15 seconds after the bomb was fired
which impacted the response of the
laser-guided bomb before landing on the
military target
these details emerge as the political
landscape is dramatically changing with
the new american president
already re-examining u.s arms sales to
saudi arabia
and the uae the british government may
also be forced to reconsider its
involvement in this war
alex crawford sky news